hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to brighter day now don't be
fooled cuz apparently this is a horror
game and I have no idea how that's gonna
be alright I'm here to play it now I
only loaded up the game that's why there
was a save game over there I didn't see
much more than this which is beautiful
actually and I'm wondering if it's
Christmas
[Music]
that wasn't there before what am I
supposed to conquer and why and how and
where am I and why am I here and whoo
hey force my way in there can I have
these I definitely can't have these are
these Mentos or drugs I can never tell
the difference oh I just wasted
something that was probably really
important to me this is interesting
experience the healing power of the
monolith okay
are those sultry sounds the sounds of
the monolith I know you're telling me
shift to run I know this who is that
what is all of this I don't understand
anything that's happening with hi what
the [ __ ] what excuse me
I like this game this game is bizarre
hey excuse you
so what is this what what is any of this
Explorer that's what I'm trying to do
but I don't understand why I'm doing it
can I have these can I have this
whatever this is I love it and I want
more of it also you all should shove it
not you but them the eyeballs hello hi
what are you why do I have you I get it
explore discover that's great oh this is
a rather acoustical shower ah I see okay
I got you hmm so I gotta be on the
lookout for the okay I gotta be on the
lookout for those things because they
can very easily sneak up on me so I got
a lot of pills here what do I do about
upon me what are they gonna do to me if
they find me what am I gonna do to me if
I find myself that's more of an
existential question but not applicable
this sinner
what the hell ow my legs
they went into my spleen they seem to be
okay I mean what am I supposed to do am
I supposed to toss these things I mean
that's all I can do really God don't do
that it's cute to dilute my amore why
did I run towards him
so there were some doors down there that
I could have opened and gone into so I
need to find a way to get back there
also I need to find a way to knock it
Hadj gee summons I know you're a giant
eyeball but you probably didn't see
nothing there's nothing in here there
was no point to coming down here so
anything over there yes everything is
horrible and I don't even know why did
you print something called manifesto
from the server
um no someone did that's not okay okay
so someone's got a manifesto over here
so wait does that sound mean that
there's mystical pills on the way and
how many do I need it's what we thought
we got two oh nine to talk to sixteen
orchestrated rebellion convinced
everyone the pills brainwash them or
something they stopped taking them a
while ago
where's 209 missing well finding a lot
of stray pills I don't think it's just
okay this is starting to make not sense
kick you out of the chopper when you
have to thank you huh you telling them
to get to the chopper okay okay okay
whoa I didn't know this was here okay
please do not throw pills this can be
distracting is that a clue don't be a
homophobe
[Music]
how did I throw again I want to go in
there I got a second battle what is in
hi what are you doing here what did I
find
I don't know what I found hello yeah I
shined a brighter light on your brighter
day hope you have a good one I'm gonna
get out of here now I still don't know
what I'm doing here this is seriously
bizarre I'm trying to piece together
exactly what's going on here and why I
mean it seems like we're in a mental
facility of some sort and they're
experimenting medicine on these poor
unsuspecting Me's sounds so reassuring
but I'm still disconcerted Lou why is
this one dark what's this one dark hello
whoa are you the model is your mom on
anomalous yeah I got three tubes now but
why and how hello toilet pills I
definitely want you
atone for what Hey
you're so spooky he's gonna turn around
whoa what is this what is this I don't
know what this is do you oh god you just
shower shut up no time for you what is
you high it's you okay that's the guy
that was just staring into the wall
before I don't know why okay
don't waste ink don't waste pills which
it seems to be what everybody's doing
over here Carrie okay hello
what are you talking about if you can
get through the front door all the way
around the east louder get the roof from
there is John there working on it and K
front door East ladder get to roof from
there what does that mean okay there's
the ladder okay so I got to get out the
front door I don't use know where the
front door is how am I gonna know where
anything else oh I get it
oh that I ball he's staring at the
monolith oh okay so the modulus is
distracting that guy because he's
basking in the glow of the monolith the
healing power of the monolith is
revealed so I got to find a way to get
to the front entrance but I don't even
know where the hell the front entrance
is okay exit okay front door must be out
here oh I thought he was gonna come
after me whoa I did not like that
[Music]
bah [ __ ] Jesus Oh criminy Christmas go
away
that guys like hypersensitive to the
know oh that's not fair okay a little
bit okay wow you're creepy why are you
there okay so now he might come back so
I'm just gonna hide until he gets back
there I just need to be very very quiet
[Music]
that's right alrighty then
okay more of it but there's a dude over
there oh god oh god oh god oh god was a
porter come up here there was no point
oh crap crap crap crap crap crap okay
good hello no don't don't don't don't
dawn dawn dawn they said in an e-mail
that I read cuz I was reading computers
that there was something at the top of
this ladder or maybe it was not this
ladder it was a difficult but it was one
ladder somewhere there's a ladder and I
need to climb it hello damn it why did I
come up here then okay alright
woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah
woah woah oh oh woah you though told a
point of all you seein Yoshio points
this is all a lie oh damn dirty lie I
can't take it anymore
what the hell is going whoa what is okay
[Music]
I fell right into it okay we're fine
we're fine we made it okay we did it we
did what we were supposed to I think I
think we're supposed to go here what is
down there do I want to go in the
mountain butthole I don't know about
that we guarantee you'll be fully
recovered by the end of your session
okay Thank You robot nurse assistant uh
whose face is apparently a painting I
don't know why I'm 0.2 this cool I'm not
gonna be able to make that herb Oh God
Oh what up pissing balls Hey oh god no
oh I thought you were going to kill me
okay what happened huh Wow okay
apparently my game crashed and now oh
whoa okay whoa hey wait a minute now
whoa okay hi why do you look like a nose
also where am I
also what the hell is going on here oh
fast light that'll be incredibly helpful
weird so weird this is so weird
why but I still don't understand any of
this this doesn't make any sense this
game is like bizarre
those guys down here okay better not
turn around you bastard you keep all
moving you all miss late I know 17 types
come through and one type of karate
I know the ancient secret art of
punching you in the balls until you
scream uncle that wasn't supposed to
sound dirty but surprisingly it did so
why am I just following this eyeball
down here stop oh god oh god oh god okay
whoa what did I find here what what are
those
what's going on why why why why dad
happen and I don't have a lot of time
for this because I gotta prepare to
leave for indie pop con I thought this
was gonna be a short indie game but
apparently it's epically long hello
goodbye now why did I die in here was
there an eyeball in here that I did not
see
whoa that was the eyeball the eyeball
wood big goddamn going going going now
what the Frick is this crap pass we
didn't see nothing
[Music]
goddamn I felt like I might have been
close to something but I have no idea so
I gotta call it quits guys I hate to
quit in the middle of a game but I mean
like I might just have to finish this up
in the next part if it's even like worth
finishing in the next part do what's
going on so if you got a solution for
this mystery it was actually quite scary
in the beginning just because I had no
idea what was going on but now it's just
confusing cuz I have no idea what's
going on so let me know what you think
this game means in the description down
below or in the comments down below let
me know what your interpretation of this
madness is possibly meaning and thank
you everybody so much for watching check
out more cool games that I played in the
past and the annotations over there or
in the description below
and as always I will see you at any
popcorn
[Music]